it's talking a guy in the audience
asking what he did for a living he goes
I'm a cabinet salesman
I was like do you like it he's like love
it
I was like what do you love about being
a cabinet sales and because I like
having dinner with my customers
oh I don't know that was a wine and dine
situation
well Todd your cabinets are all
installed what do you think I love them
I'll put my Cocoa Puffs in there really
soon
well Todd now that they're all installed
I guess it's Bistro time right
time for the traditional post cabinet
installation
celebratory dinner
what are you hankering for
I'm sorry I'm having dinner with the
guys who steam clean my drapes
it's been quite a day breakfast with my
exterminator
happy hour drinks with my plumber
you know maybe I can have lunch tomorrow
you know what I'm going to apple picking
with the guys who reach her out of my
bathroom top